I am Jarrod I am one of the partners at
YC and I'm gonna talk about starting
hard tech and biotech companies set of
curiosity in the colonies here today who
i who is starting something like a heart
attack or a bio company okay a handful
of folks nice excellent excellent
um across all of start-up school there
are actually over a thousand companies
that are doing hard tech or biotech
things which i think is really cool
so this talk is gonna be most relevant
for them but also for other folks who
like might think about doing a company
like this in the future even if you're
not right now here is what I'm going to
talk about and define what a hard tech
company is I'm going to talk about the
two most common heart tech two most
common problems hard tech companies face
and how to solve them and then we're
gonna talk a bit about fundraising
specifically for hard tech companies
building on what Caroline just talked
about so what is a hard tech company
this is my definition because I couldn't
find a good one on the Internet
so the way I see it is a hard tech
company is a company that fulfills two
criteria one it will take a lot of time
and money to build your first product
and two even if you had lots of time and
money it's not clear if it would be
possible to build it at all companies
like this are a little bit different
from other kinds of companies and
interestingly it doesn't have to be a
physical product and this doesn't say
anything specifically about Science and
Technology it actually applies to like a
pretty broad range of companies and
another way if thinking about this is
the difference between market risk and
technical risk so if your company is
building a normal website or a mobile
app you probably have mostly market risk
which is to say you have a new idea it's
not totally clear if people are going to
want this thing that you're making but
you probably don't have much tactical
risk because building websites and apps
is a solved problem at this point
whereas with a heart a company you're
probably doing something that clearly
people would want if you could do it the
question is whether you actually can do
it okay so starting at heart tech
companies sounds hard I mean hard as
even in the name and I think this scares
off a lot of founders who
otherwise start one and I think this is
like non-obvious misconception so I'm
going to try to address it here is a
quote by Sam Altman that sounds like the
complete paradox so it Sam said is in
many ways it's easier to start a hard
company than an easy company that sounds
like it doesn't make any sense um but to
explain what Sam I think it's actually
like a pretty deep truth and so to
explain what Sam meant by this I'm going
to tell you a story about a company
called boom who's heard of boom a few
folks okay so um boom is a YC company
from three years ago and they're doing
something completely awesome they're
building this it is a supersonic
passenger jet to replace the concorde it
will fly at Mach 2.2 and taking from San
Francisco to Tokyo in five hours no joke
they're really doing this the founder of
boom is a guy named Blake and boom is
not Blake's first company before he
started boom
he started a very ordinary company that
made a mobile shopping an Blake came and
he taught her to IC dinner and he
reflected on the differences between his
first company the mobile shopping app
and his second company boom and he says
something really insightful um when he
was building his mobile shopping app
getting the product live was easy you
can build a mobile shopping app in like
a few weeks but then everything after
that is really hard see it's hard to get
pressed to write about your mobile
shopping app because it's not an
interesting story it's hard to get
really talented employees to want to
work on it it's hard to get investors to
want to meet with you to hear about your
mobile shopping app ensure it's just
like hard to get people to care about it
and so while launching the product is
easy turning the product into a really
big company it's actually really hard
whereas with boom it's exactly the
opposite building a supersonic jet is
like incredibly hard but everything else
around it is really easy and from the
very beginning back when boom was like
idea Blake was able to get some of the
most talented people in the world to
want to help him we are living at a
unique time in the world where it has
become easier than ever before to start
a hard tech company there is an
incredible amount of investor demand to
fund really crazy ambitious ideas like
Moo so while you will have to raise a
lot more money to do a company like this
is also possible to raise a lot more
money to do a company like this and an
interesting thing is that the market
doesn't seem to firmly fully internalize
this yet because most YC applications
are not for companies like this and I
think one reason that founders don't
start companies that are super ambitious
like this is because it's like really
intimidating I mean as you guys know
like starting any kind of company is
really intimidating but it seems like
it's gonna be easier if you start a
company that's building something simple
like a mobile shopping up and the the
like counterintuitive thing that Sam
realized that I think is true is that
it's only easier to get started it isn't
necessarily easier to turn into a really
successful company not everyone knows
how big a part of YC hard tech and
biotech are so I just wanted to give you
a few quick stats
um at YC we funded over 250 bio
companies and buy a couple hundred hard
tech companies as well YC is actually
the largest BIOS seed investor in the
world and the largest hard Tech seed
investor in the world
um this includes accelerators seed funds
every kind of investor and here's
something that most people don't know um
hard tech companies that apply to YC
actually have about a 10x higher
acceptance rate than other kinds of
applications I don't completely know why
that is I suspect it's something to do
with like certain kinds of founders
being attracted to really ambitious
ideas so a really common question that I
get from hard tech companies is like I
am starting a biotech company how much
of ycs advice applies to me a lot of it
seems geared towards other kinds of
companies and the answer is actually
most of it still applies I went through
the startup school curriculum this is
the start of school 2019 curriculum and
I highlighted all the lectures that are
typically relevant for our tech
companies in green and the ones that are
typically not relevant at least at the
early stages in red and as you can see
there is a lot more green than red and
this is my experience working with YC
companies that are doing hard tech and
biotech stuff which is that while there
are some differences there are a lot
more similarities than differences okay
let's talk about the two biggest
problems specific to hard tech companies
so if you guys remember Michael Seibel
talk about MVPs he talked about how some
companies have a heavy MVP that is it's
gonna take them a really long time and
typically lots of money to build a first
product this is the case for most hard
tech and biotech companies so if you're
in the position where you need millions
of dollars to build your first product
and you don't have millions of dollars
right now what do you do
the simple answer to this question is
you have to figure out some way to make
some progress on your idea that doesn't
require millions of dollars that is
easier said than done
so to help give you guys some
inspiration for how you might do that
I'm going to walk through seven examples
of YC companies that were doing hard
tech and biotech things that did exactly
that
so the first one is boom so booms hack
was they started off by doing a bunch of
things that don't really cost any money
at all here are some of the things that
they did they assembled a team of top
advisors in the space to give them like
credibility they built computer
simulations that showed that they have a
design that could work
they built like a plastic model like a
couple feet long that they could like
take around to people to show them what
they're like a vision of this plane
would look like and then they took that
model and they went around to a bunch of
Airlines and they showed them the
plastic plane model and they use that to
get interest from Airlines to show that
there would be customer demand if they
were to build the plane and they use
basically all of these things in order
to raise the money that they needed to
actually build the plane there's a y-z
company called solute
which does something really awesome they
use synthetic biology to produce
hydrogen peroxide so on the left is a
photo of their current hydrogen peroxide
plant which is enormous and produces
truckloads of hydrogen peroxide that
they ship all around the country
obviously this plant cost a lot of money
to build but on the right side is their
MVP this is what they had when they
apply it to Y C it is a beaker that can
produce about 1 cup of hydrogen peroxide
what this beaker proved the concept of
their new industrial process for
creating hydrogen peroxide which is like
the core idea of the company and
basically they just like started with
the beaker and then they progressively
scaled up to larger and larger
installations until they have the giant
hydrogen peroxide plant so air X is a YC
company that originally planned to make
their own medical device making a
medical device is really hard their
original plan was going to take like
several years and millions of dollars in
order to get FDA approval for this new
device and then they realized that they
could launch a basic version of the same
core service they hope to launch by
using an existing medical device that
was already approved and writing some
software around it now it's not as good
is that like a ventral long-term vision
but it was like a good hack to build
like something simple that worked it
worked well enough and because of this
plan they were able to get live during
YC in less than 3 months with no FDA
approval notable Labs is a YC company
that is developing new drugs for cancer
developing new drugs for cancer is super
expensive it takes a super long time and
so the way they got started was by
providing services to screen tumors to
pharma companies the services that they
ran enable them to generate with revenue
and data that they're now using to
develop their own drugs astronomy that
builds telecommunication satellites and
launches them into space that is
obviously not a cheap thing to do it
turns out actually that the cheapest
telecommunication satellite that is
useful cost like at least 10 million
dollar
to build and launch and so estranja was
to start with a test satellite of the
satellite in this photo was their first
satellite they built it in less than
three months during YC and for less than
$50,000
now this satellite doesn't do anything
really useful like you can't sell it but
by launching an actual fully functional
satellite into space and showing that
they could do that they were able to
like and generate the credibility that
they needed to go and raise the money to
launch like a full-scale useful
telecommunication satellite last example
of Ginkgo Bioworks is a YC company that
does genetic engineering of organisms
and in order to engineer their first
organisms they were able need like
millions of dollars and so their hack
was they went around to some large
companies and they closed contracts to
create those organisms before they had
actually made the organisms the
contracts basically said if ginko makes
these organisms we will pay you lots of
money and they use those contracts and
they took those contracts around to
investors as proof of customer demand
and they use that to raise the millions
of dollars from investors that they
needed to actually make the organisms
that they had promised to customers so
basically they sold it before they meet
it and this is a very generalizable
technique that a lot of heart that
companies use in one form or another
okay so that brings me to the second
most common heart tech problem which is
how do you prove people will want your
product if you haven't built it yet this
is important for found for you to prove
to yourself because the last thing you
want to do is spend years working on
some product only to find that people
don't actually want it at the end but
it's also important to prove it to
investors and so here are a couple of
ways that you can do that the best way
is through pre-sales so ideally you just
sell your product before you build it
this is what people do on Kickstarter a
good example of this is a company called
jetpack aviation from two batches ago
which is building the flying motorcycle
in the picture and what jeff macke
aviation did was they ran a pre-sale
campaign and they basically sold flying
motorcycles to a bunch of people on the
internet to prove that people would want
them unfortunately
doing pre-sales is not always possible
if you're doing
for example if you're doing something
medical that requires FDA approval it's
actually illegal to do pre-sales so
don't do that so because of that we
created something called a letter of
intent or LOI and a letter of intent is
a non-binding contract to buy your
product when it's ready now a
non-binding contract seems like kind of
a silly idea like non-binding contract
it's kind of like a paradox but um it
turns out that it's actually kind of
very clever construct um because it's
not binding he doesn't actually commit
the customer to bite but because it
looks like a contract customers take it
really seriously
it's easy when you're talking to a
customer for them to like be polite and
casually say like sure I buy your thing
if it ever worked someday because it's
like no commitment for them but if you
ask them to sign an LOI you'll find out
if they're actually really serious about
buying your product and investors knew
that so here's just some quick advice
about lis if you decide to go down this
route the more specific the LOI is the
more valuable it is the good LOI
includes all the following information
the cool thing is if you can get a
customer to sign an LOI like this it
literally gives you a roadmap for what
you need to build in order to generate
revenue from your product okay the last
thing I want to talk about is
fundraising for hard tech and biotech
companies most hard tech companies will
not be able to bootstrap they will
typically have to raise money from
investors so part of building the hard
tech company is coming up with a smart
fundraising plan and sometimes hard tech
companies will come to me at the
beginning of the batch but the
fundraising plan that looks something
like this this fundraising plan is like
hey I have a really good idea I need 50
million dollars to go and build it so
I'm just gonna go pitch to a bunch of
investors until somebody gives me 50
million dollars and then I'll and I'll
be all set I don't recommend this plan
when I see a plan like this it makes me
think of this
I just like standing in front of a wall
staring up at the wall the wall is like
the $50,000,000 like impossible
fundraise because the the fact is it's
just like impossible to get investors to
give you 50 million dollars for an idea
you have to make some progress first and
so what you want to do is a fundraising
plan that looks like this this still
gets you to 50 million dollars but it
splits it into five discrete races that
start very small and the key thing here
is that for each of these fund races you
want to have specific milestones that
you hit so like you start off who want
to be able to make some progress with
your company before you raised any money
at all like how boom did and then you
want to use that in order to raise maybe
like a couple hundred thousand dollars
and then you want to use the couple
hundred thousand dollars to make more
progress which enables you to raise like
a million dollars and then you want to
use the million dollars to make more
progress you can raise four million
dollars and so on and well the general
principle is simple and easy to
understand a lot of this skill in
building a hard tech company is in
fine-tuning this fundraising plan so
that like all the steps are like as
small as they possibly can be because
the most important part of this
fundraising plan is that new step should
be too large it like by the time you go
out and start trying to raise a fifteen
million dollar series a you have to
actually have accomplished enough that
investors will give you that largest
fundraising round otherwise you're just
gonna hit another one of those like
fundraising walls and so really good
hard tech founders are maniacal about
like pushing down the size of each of
those steps so that each step is as
small as possible which makes it as easy
as possible for them to achieve the
milestones that they need to raise the
next round of funding and that is all
that I have about our tech and biotech
companies
[Applause]
okay we'll do some questions whenever
there sure so the the question was of
the examples I didn't mention any ai ai
companies and that's a great point I
probably should have included one
there's a really famous YC company
that's an AI company called Cruz has
heard of Cruz Cruz built self-driving
cars and they got acquired by GM for of
billion dollars and yeah Cruz's a great
example of a hard tech company um the
original Cruz car was built in less than
three months during YC Kyle basically
just like was in a garage building this
car and writing code for like three
months solid and by the end of YC he had
an MVP that he could use to drive on the
highway um to show that like basically
he could build a self-driving car over
there yeah so the question is have I
ever worked with any nonprofit hard tech
companies no do you have one yes okay um
we should maybe talk about that after
I'd be interested to hear how that could
work any other question over here people
want this and you're also trying to get
like companies to trust you to like I
understand some of the contractors on
the finding and that some of them might
be like if you deliver they're like they
give you X or whatever
but it seems like a lot of companies
would want to like plan specifically
around like okay if I see these
organisms or whatever like do I have a
plan that's definitely gonna get me the
organisms or am I like maybe if I have
them that's great
a weird situation so how do you get
around that yes who I'll try to
paraphrase the question it was like it
seems like getting an LOI would be hard
because the company doesn't know if
you're actually going to be able to
deliver it and they have to like plan
around that and the answer is yes it is
hard to get LOI is like even though LOI
ZAR not binding they're actually pretty
hard to get and the weird thing is that
the very fact that they're hard is it
makes them valuable if they were easy
they wouldn't be worth anything so the
the reason that they're kind of valuable
is that it is hard to get a company to
do that they'll typically only do it if
you're solving a really critical pain
point for them yeah but just like a nice
to have it's gonna be hard to get an LOI
which is actually really good signal for
you to know that you're working on
something that's a really big problem
for them yeah yeah in fact yeah about in
the middle you yes okay so the question
was is there a difference between
hardtack and moonshot ideas as that
terminology question the answer's no I I
was using the terms interchangeably so
the question is if your idea like is
disruptive how do you prove how do you
prove that you're gonna be able to make
it or how do you prove the people will
want it if you make it okay both well
that's kind of like the examples are
kind of about some ideas for like how to
how to do that like kind of the key the
key thing for our tech companies is to
figure out ways to prove as much as
possible
as early as possible in order to reduce
the like perceived risk that the idea is
going to work as the more you can reduce
the risk the easier is going to be to
raise money in order to get to the next
you reach the decision leader because it
might not be here in its innovation of
meat which person's actually going to be
and we're okay so the question is for a
hard tech company where you're selling
it to into an enterprise and there's one
person who's like the decision maker
about buying it but there's another
person who had actually be the user how
do you how do you manage that situation
right okay so this is actually like a
really cool thing about the Elda why is
that the LOI basically forces you to do
a dry run of the sales process that you
will eventually do when you have the
product before you have the product so
sometimes like sales are complicated
because you have a bunch of different
stakeholders in an organization who may
have different incentives and by trying
to get an LOI out of the organization
you will basically uncover that Pat and
you will figure out what you need to do
in order to appease all the different
stakeholders in order to get the sale so
how can actually be really valuable
feedback to get early on in your company
last one over here so the question is
like how do you find like yeah like
founders and early employees or hard
tech companies the good news actually is
I found that hard tech companies tend to
have an easier time recruiting than
other kinds of companies kind of like
how I was talking about boom because
talented people are drawn
to words like crazy ambitious ideas so I
actually think it's like a real
recruiting advantage to be working on
something that's really like crazy and
ambitious like that but in terms of like
where to find people I mean kind of like
everywhere just like you know hiring
employees it like it's gonna be hard
even if you're doing a hard tight
company is gonna be hard if I'm like
like super talented people yeah cool
that's all we have time for thank you
everyone
[Applause]
you